Lucy wrote it Lucy said how easily could
someone convince you that you had lost
your mind either that your name isn't
truly your name or that you don't know
people you think you know or you don't
have the job you think you have I wonder
about this sometimes Louis sometimes I
get to a place where I say okay let's
say I showed up today to the studio and
I looked in the door to whatever has
been the studio for several months and
there's like a bunch of stock traders in
there right and I'd say what the hell I
we've had our office here we have a
lease here stock traders moved in like
what that what the hell's going on and
I'd go up to the leasing office and I'd
say hey guys uh my office is gone like
that their stock traders in there and
then if the leasing person who runs the
building said I'm sorry who are you I go
now a david pakman but we beliefs inc
week Tenley's and they go I'm sorry sir
who uh did you have an appointment at
someone or how how long could that go
let's assume it was a prank or whatever
not before I seriously started to
question like a Miami T my questioning
my sanity I don't know the answer I mean
it's scary to think about yeah I'd like
to think that it would it would be very
very difficult to convince me that I've
lost my mind yeah mostly because I like
to think that I have good attention to
detail and that you might make the
littlest mistake and I'll say aha I got
you right just your effin with me but I
don't know i mean it i guess there could
come a time where i do lose my mind yeah
but i wouldn't think that i lost my mind
and someone would actually have to
convince me that i had well I guess
that's the question what would it take
for you to not didn't the instinct most
people would have is someone's tricking
me right you go to a restaurant and you
go to pay and they say sir these are US
dollars we take whatever we take
Motamedi bills here or call it whatever
right you say well who does the United
States like US dollars sir US dollars
haven't been accepted here for five
years like five years ago the u.s.
change currency what now it's crazy you
look around you ask the person next to
you they show you their wallet it's all
these alternative bills right i mean how
long would how long could that go before
you just give up and say i think i think
this is true
guy somehow have missed that this is the
reality I think maybe if I went a whole
day yeah and everything was just
completely different yeah it's it's
conceivable to me that by the end of
that day I would be questioning my
sanity yeah and that is I mean I'm
talking everything it just imagine that
situation you just described happening
to in every sense in every seven seas
different you go to your apartment
there's no apartment there someone else
Liz that you knock on your key doesn't
work you knock on the door they say I've
lived here for two years I don't know
what you're talking about you go
downstairs to your car and there is no
car and when you call the police they
say okay what's the license plate give
it to them and they say that licenses
for a different car and someone else all
together it would take a lot is what
you're saying it would take a lot but I
guess if it were really piled on thick
yeah it might not take more than a day
send me your thoughts about this I've
asked a few people off the air about
this knowing that we were going to talk
about it today uh it seems like a
horrible situation and I can only assume
Louis that first people with certain
mental illness that probably happens
more often than you might imagine right
this just complete out of place feeling
this the feeling that you get when you
go to where you left your car and the
cars been towed and you don't see it and
there's this for most of us a
microsecond where you go what what just
happened here right at this micro second
of confusion imagine that lasting hours
or days and it really is a horrible
horrible thought I guess I never want to
be in that situation we have a fantastic
bonus show today you'll have to tune in
to see what we talked about david
pakman.com slash membership get instant
access to exclusive member benefits
today